schafgarbe strahlen lose kamele oder bei
fuß in weiten teilen deutschlands und
europas werden diese pflanzen oft als
störend empfunden sie werden vernichtet
und entsorgt oft einfach aus
unwissenheit
doch wer sich wie peter franke mit
wildkräutern auskennt findet in der
natur schmackhafte zutaten zum kocht
umgangssprachlich wildkräuter und die
informationen sind unkräuter das total
fehl am platze ist
ich glaube wir sollten diese unkräuter
richtig hochleben lassen
deswegen müssen die wertigkeit der
kräuter in den mittelpunkt stellen
welche guten eigenschaften sie habe in
den wildkräuter sind gesund manche
liefern weit mehr vitamine und
mineralstoffe als so manches gemüse
peter franke sammelt sie auf wiesen und
feldern in der umgebung von verben in
einem kleinen ort mitten im spreewald im
osten deutschlands
ich freue mich über die schafgarbe das
ganze jahr mache ich so ab und nehme ich
für die butter für den quark trocknen
als tee als bart und natürlich das beste
was ich daraus mache ist mein
magenbitter
[Musik]
essbare wildkräuter eignen sich
hervorragend für das zubereiten vieler
speisen zusammen mit daniel noack einem
seiner küche bereitet er für sein
gasthaus ein pastor auf brennessel basis
zu dafür verwenden sie nicht nur die
blätter wichtiges bei der prämisse dass
man den weiblichen samen nimmt das ist
das beste nahrungsergänzungsmittel
hier sind alle inhaltsstoffe drinnen
zudem leicht nussigen geschmack der
brennessel passen geröstete walnüsse für
eine gute konsistenz wird alles mit
rapsöl vermengt und mit dem mörser
zerstoßen und fertig ist das pesto
wildkräuter eignen sich auch für salate
die kirche nehmen blut am vermögen zahn
und autolack und ganz wichtig die
zipperlein gut schmeckt wie kohlrabi
möhren der giersch soll bei rheuma und
erkältungen helfen seien vitamin c
gehalt ist vier mal höher als der von
zitronen die kräuter werden zerkleinert
mit rapsöl vermischt und dann mit
ringelblumen und tomaten verfeinert das
tue ich meine ganze seele in die
schüssel oder in den kochtopf reinwerfen
und ich muss mich selber erfreuen und
diese dürfte also mit allen sinnen zu
arbeiten das ist das entscheidende das
ist das erfolgsrezept
auch anika krause möchte dass
kräuterwissen zurück in den alltag
bringen die ausgebildete
pflanzenheilkunde rinn bietet
wildkräuter wanderungen in berlin an
denn auch in großstädten wachsen
zahlreiche wildkräuter sowie das knopf
kraut auch als franzosen kraut bekannt
aber wirklich wichtig ist vor allem dass
eisen
das schönste kompliment ist wenn die
leute nach einer wildkräuter wohnung so
durch die gegend gehen und immer gucken
was da alles auf der erde ist und was
die wir nutzen können
ich musste ein bisschen unser beitrag zu
die heimische natur wieder mehr
wertzuschätzen und dadurch auch zu
schützen und kein golf rasen im garten
anzulegen
wichtige regeln beim sammeln stark
befahrene straßen meiden und nur die
pflanzen pflücken die man kennt mit
ihrem start-up gut stellt anika krause
auch essenzen aus wildkräutern hier das
alte wissen über die heimische
pflanzenwelt kommt bei der gruppe an
[Musik]
glaube dass gerade als junger mensch
eben das gar nicht so bewusst in der
stadt wenn man so aufwächst wie was für
eine vielfalt eigentlich das an
wildkräutern bietet seit ich auch mit
wildkräutern kochen was ich mache ist
meine mutter auch sehr früh
beeindruckter vermieten und ich konnte
halt so ja die ganzen wie vielseitig
wildkräuter sind weiß auch peter franke
er verwendet sie nicht nur zum kochen
sondern macht sie haltbar und
verarbeitet sie zu marmelade gelee sirup
essig und öl
[Musik]
seine faszination für heimische kräuter
möchte er an seine gäste weitergeben
wenn dieser konsumgesellschaft wo alles
verfügbar ist wo man nicht mehr auf die
gesundheit so stark achtet wie wir
eigentlich sollten sollten die
wildkräuter wirklich eine neue rolle und
bedeutung in der gesamten gesellschaft
spielen
[Musik]